the daring act of terror that shook
Paris and the world at the plenary a key
vote on anti-terrorism but against the
backdrop of an EU summit of heads of
state back in brussels on thursday a
reminder for member states the need to
act faster la lutte ante todo esta bien
sur la trata de Bourgh como si parla
sample miss inada decision deja Otellini
la Pueblo recede o alguna parte de la
mesa nervosa Litella passenger name
record the collection of traveler
information has emerged as one of the
frontrunners in the fight against
terrorism but some questions remain Lama
su su viaje me validate associate a okay
Rose let Elise moda Penner key digital
more de consejo headed on a ad vitam wat
acabo de da extreme along Napa
proportional Oh bleep Oh sweetie
Seleucus a key block la presencia Tiki
permit hey dog morte la sécurité hell in
opa théorique no conceit why i blame
also laid at the door outside influences
like saudi arabia funding an extremist
mind sent but if the debate was to have
a collective thought it was this for you
up to look within itself at the seeds of
hatred in its own citizens we have to be
a little bit critically to ourself
because a lot of these terrorists are
French original German original from
from Europe so europeans and that's why
we have to rethink what what went wrong
in the past what we did we wrong and one
major question is education one major
question is integration with Parliament
approving is resolution or
anti-terrorism all eyes turn to Brussels
whether hope that real solutions so
desperately needed are found
you